[Music]
the prisoner we snatch last night is a
courier for a man yes it Kaleo who's the
interrogator Alice Racine
we need your skill set we need you back
on the front line the prisoner table go
order an attack on an American target in
the UK it's thought to be biological
we have two other members of his mosque
in custody and like you they ever known
the plane ride in their future tell me
the tallest
important just my personal life Sara
this is not a secure line we need you
for an emergency assignment in London
we've got a prisoner waiting I leave
early on it the hell are you talking
about
we have an informant in station so we
have been penetrated
[Music]
what is going on in London that involves
the CIA and a terrorist strike am i
fires committing every available asset
to this you think I've unlocked a source
for a terrorist
I've an eye for talent I trained you in
the country's interest what's your
status in danger someone is hunting me
I'm thinking I'm the only friends you go
we're prisoners gone to ground I do oh
we're City getting away when it counts
[Music]
global viruses are the biggest threat to
mankind each one a ticking bomb
incubations false start the trainer she
has to be stopped
let me just on three hours once armed
you got five minutes tell me how to stop
it I don't care
[Music]
with a target
there's no time for guessing
we're all in God's hands like to think
we have a say
[Music]